house republicans calling on homeland
security secretary alejandro mayorkas to
visit yuma arizona saying that
san diego the entire southern border
proves the severity of the crisis
arizona congressman andy biggs member of
the house oversight and reform committee
joins us live now obviously congressman
the entire southern border is a disaster
that number one million arrests in just
six months alone
to your point in that op-ed is there any
chance myoka says yeah i'm going to go
down check this out you know this
problem that i and joe biden and the
entire bite administration caused in the
first place
well first of all he would have to
acknowledge that there is a problem on
the border and that he felt he needed to
get down there and see it i'm not sure
that he understands the gravity of it i
mean this is the dhs secretary and i
don't understa i don't think he
understands how serious this is
so when you when you find 23 folks
people
coming into the country who are on the
terrorist watch list and yet you release
hundreds of thousands of people into the
country and you you know that you have
between half a million and eight hundred
thousand got aways
that means you just don't know how many
people are on the terrorist watch list
or other criminal criminally violent so
he needs to get down there
and and no more of this stuff where he
goes down and says well we're going to
do this or that he needs to go down and
say this is as bad as it gets quit
coming we're not going to allow you in
you just mentioned the suspected or
known terrorists that were encountered
that number 23 seems awfully low in
light of the number of people that have
just crossed this border can you hazard
a guess as to how many godaways are now
in the homeland threatening our nation
well the the word i got was that there
were about eight hundred thousand
uh got aways last year
and if that's the case and you look at
23 out of 2 million i mean you're still
you're still adding to that list
and folk
people with information tell me that
maybe about 40 or 50 that actually
made it into the country we don't know
we we simply don't know we don't know
where they're coming from all these
folks we don't know what their intention
is and we don't know whether it's
malevolent to the united states and how
big a risk the country is at until you
start getting hold of that border
situation and they're they're not doing
that they're making it actually worse
instead of better that math that you
just worked through is terrifying
absolutely terrifying and the number one
question i get asked congressman i'm
sure you get this ass asked us too why
why is the bite administration doing
this i get asses from democrats
republican we just mentioned the
terrorists we mentioned the overall
number and then there's this video of
the
border patrol agents being accused of
whipping people trying to corral them at
the border when we now know these agents
no wrongdoing was found this is a proper
procedure it's like the biden
administration in their refusal to
apologize for their rush to judgment as
to what they saw has absolutely no idea
how our border is secured or what needs
to be done to keep our nation safe in
the first place do you have any reason
why they continue to have their head
literally in the sand since the moment
they took office
yeah my position is that they campaigned
on an open border this is exactly what
an open border looks like they are
keeping a campaign promise
and
the fact that they refuse to make things
better tells you that this is willful it
is purposeful
nobody keeps
bad policies in place unless they they
like the results of those bad policies
and these are bad policies we could go
through specifically give you specifics
how policies have changed but the
reality is this is purposeful they're
playing to their base i suppose uh
beyond that we don't know the the the
bad intentions that the biden
administration has i personally don't
think uh president biden is uh cognizant
and capable of understanding the the the
full danger this country's in because of
the southern border crisis but secretary
marcus does and he's not doing anything
he should resign or my impeachment
resolution should be heard it's a borrow
from our last segment easter bunny can't
protect us at the southern border like
you can protect biden from answering
questions if republicans take back
congress as is expected
what can they do to blunt biden's impact
on the border which at that point by the
january of next year is going to be even
more
you're right it will be even worse there
are three things that we can do we have
to use the the must-pass legislation
that they're gonna that president biden
wants and we need to make sure that none
of that passes unless there's curative
measures on the border
second thing you have to have
investigative committees bring people in
who are making these bad decisions and
hold them up to spectacle for the whole
country to see
how bad it is and which will compel them
in some instances to make changes to
their policy and the third thing is you
actually have to hold people accountable
with other mechanisms i mean quite
frankly that's why i've introduced
resolutions to impeach secretary
mayorkas because
what he has done
is allowed literally millions of people
into this country illegally and our
border is absolutely not secure it's
dangerous we we haven't even got into
drug trafficking we haven't even talked
about that implication we haven't talked
about the sex trafficking that's going
on
and all the things that are happening at
the border that we can report on
so i think you need to impeach him and
and once that impeachment goes i think
he'll resign before he gets impeached
and maybe we can get somebody else in
there who will actually take
active measures to secure our border and
congressman when you think of the
department of homeland security it was
born out of 9 11 when it was let's
protect america at all costs and now 20
years later this it's sad congressman
andy biggs we appreciate your time and
your insight this morning thank you sir
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now